how are you how are you nice to see you
again it's been a long time I know it's
been like 24 hours yeah at least A lot's
happened in 24 hours you went for a walk
with the cast you took them out for
dinner you know all the gossip I did
they told me and they loved it yeah I
became the Toronto tour guide that told
you this is my city it really is and how
did you pick the restaurant you just
uh there's a place called Coastline Road
on Adelaide that I used to when I've
been staying here before I was on like
basically corner of Blue Jays Way in
Adelaide and that was my joints about
four or five times a week so I always go
see those guys on them in town Monty and
Chef over at kosan Road check it out
check it I haven't been okay you're
gonna have to take me let's go yeah yeah
all right best Pad Thai in Toronto
really I get down with the Penang Curry
yeah I like that I like the golden curry
chicken have you tried that yes that's
good that's good you know the fact that
you're here with everybody and the fact
that you spent so much time together and
really got to know each other this must
be special for you it is you know that's
the that's the glory of long-form
Storytelling you know you get to bonds
and hopefully you know the Journey's
just beginning you know be great to be
back here you know God willing in two
three years at the end of The Journey
you know by that point we'll all hate
each other
season two's gonna happen
your lips to God's ears I don't know you
know they take a while over in the
streaming platforms to make their
decisions you know it's not like the old
days where you know you would get the
reports on the whatever it was three
days later and you knew exactly how many
people were watching the show and you
could kind of predict yourself what the
future held it's kind of not like that
with the streaming platforms well I
understand you know dad jokes that
that's what you did on set I don't know
so I want to hear your best dad joke and
I will give you my best dad joke okay
why uh the lobsters not give to charity
why because they're shellfish
you wanna hear mine yeah what did Sushi
a say to Sushi B wasabi
it's really good we're gonna use it
aren't you
you know one of the great things also is
the fact that when you see a photo of
you on your motorcycle it's become like
a signature for you from Sons of Anna
Grace to this do you ride on my
motorcycle I don't I did for about nine
years solid um while I was doing
sunshine road like I was a health Angel
and I took a lot of risks and got away
with a lot and then as soon as we
finished the show it was like the spell
was broken and all of a sudden I started
to worry about being on a bike and I
just felt like that's not though you got
a ride with confidence you know you're
thinking about what could go wrong
likelihood that something might go wrong
so yeah I haven't been on a bike in
maybe three years but you weren't sat
with it right in India yeah sorry I rode
in the show but not not in my life now
would you prefer let's just say you
became James Bond because people have
been talking about you becoming James
Bond would you like to ride a motorcycle
or a Aston Martin
yeah last month I actually don't ride a
bike that much in shantaram you know it
was just okay it was just you know
obviously you have a little bit of a
following in television from riding a
bike so I thought I think Apple just
thought maybe they would capitalize on
it I hope they didn't create an
expectation we're not going to deliver
because this is definitely not Sons of
Anarchy in India I like I like that I
really like that now this is 80 themed
what's your favorite 80s song
Gloria I don't know I don't even know if
that's 80s
[Applause]
yeah I love it okay I'll see you later
thank you so much for being here
congratulations